all right I'm Lord podcast we have here
what's going on here okay these guys
right now are going to play the
invisible robots
okay their goal is obviously not to kill
your team you cannot do that the TV's
invincible right so their goal is to
destroy structures on a map called The X
Factor's okay they also need to
it's the only way to get the mechanics
work again invisible versus invincible
yeah right now last year you guys had a
presence in PAX East before I believe
speaking of one of your reps he was a
great guy and I guess the question I
have from you is at that point I
remember it being a potential cosplay
game right so at it as it currently
stands we still have cross play involved
[Music]
you read my mind the long game and what
you say as far as the engagement so
forth has having after charge in gay
Patti Phil it's been helpful as far as
the online community as far as the
players
charge if you write out the charge
you're gonna come into the official
server all saying oh yeah there's an
awesome community
awesome yeah so right now to get them
queued up right so it getting queued up
we got MJ to boss or gameplay shadow MJ
to pause as one of the lords of the
round you know these are we checking out
the gameplay right now now another
question I guess I had for you was one
thing that we've been seeing as far as
switch titles are concerned I notice is
switch PC Xbox right now sometimes they
get queued at a different queues you
know are the switch players in the same
cross Blake you okay so noisy edges yeah
it's don't come in
I mean
the principal issue when you do a
12-play game is always about
yes we have our own dedicated server so
everything needs to be approved by all
the back burns
gotcha so you think we're still going to
the legalese Park right now that's cool
man it's still good that Lisa T it's
even being considered and I know switch
owners would really really love to get
their hands on this title man this seems
like almost like a perfect fit for the
switch now as far as I see the
characters we got enforcers we got to
stop going on now or are we also looking
to add more individual characters later
that's what we're showcasing right now
one new class on each side
we've got
Chanin on the robot side which is the
first robot to have a cannon only robot
I can shoot down which can be both
enemies so he's got an airy okay main
goal is more like controlling the ground
because you can place turrets and the
vice that reveal the robots but it does
not reveal them and give you a hint that
they are nearby this device capture so
you gotta keep track of it this gun is
really less powerful but its main goal
is revealing your feeling to you so he's
are real helpful to your teammates to
show where those invisible guys pretty
much are the auto turrets are very crazy
nice nice now what inspirations would
you say that a have to charge kind of
suits are I'm getting so a little bit of
overwatch Bob's getting did you know
would you say some of the inspirations
and attack
or the team side there was a lot of
people nice I quit yes America part
and of course like rocket League as well
or some elements like the game are so
quick and sharp you can just like hump
in there's a lot of action right away
and then it's not in your oh maybe I
have time for another one quick get in
get out
but I would say those are you know fair
now now are we utilizing as far as
engine is concerned we look it's just
looking at yeah we look at at unity what
are we looking at okay and what can you
tell us about the engine as far as like
is it really flexible for you guys
what's your experience has been with the
engine itself it looks really good this
is veteran status build throughout 30
games with unity so kind of kind of was
the the right choice just like keep
going everyone at the studio is is where
unity for long times fair enough fair
enough square easy for us to system you
feel
like there's always there's more about
what do you know how you want to use it
you guys both engine will to again
basically so in your experience based on
your history the experience of making
games into the stage you like you feel
unities a little bit more easier than
the Pinetree point it's a little easier
[Music]
if you if you learn so this new content
now getting back to F chart this is
coming out as is as of right now or what
are you looking at as far as discontent
so it's exclusive exclusive packs
exclusive you heard that purse so we're
getting it again and we gonna get it
across all platforms okay awesome and
have the charges in the building looking
fantastic empty the boss our here
killing and working doing his thing
hunting robots it looks really cool man
and I would assume communication is
extremely vital and it's at it like this
especially with that new character
that's revealing everybody yeah all
right man that's it once we got here
after charge live PAX East exclusive new
content coming very soon about a week
away hopefully we're almost there two
weeks man absolute pleasure to have you
in the building
IOP Harlow podcast Lords of gaming
dotnet and we're out of here man
fees